the way  to visualize properly is to visualize  the bridge  between where you are  and where you need to go the bridge yes  and particularly  the horrible stuff  so let's use your example of the  marathon  the vision board would be lewis crossing  the battle exactly  yes i did it exactly  that will not help you because when you  hit mile 13 on the actual race and it is  sleeting rain you say why am i doing  this yes and it feels nothing like that  thing on your vision board you're going  to start a negative dialogue i can't do  this my knees hurt this is not what i  thought it was going to be i'm not ready  for this i didn't train for this i'm  running new york i trained in l.a are  you running in new york l.a okay good  well then at least you're trained in the  right weather so on and on and on and  you are going to tank yourself